Foreign student in France,
turn all towards alternation
starting in Septemberdeux-mille-vingt-quatre.
Why?
I advise any foreign student in France to
turn to the
training from September
deux-mille-vingt-quatre?
Because,
being alternating,
we have so many,
so many advantages.
First of all,
uh.
We don't pay,
because the French State
and our company code,
they cover fees.
So already,
we have no stress on how to finance
our studies.
turn all to
training from September
deux-mille-vingt-quatre.
Currently,
we are trained
for the profession to which we aspire to practice in the future.
We are trained for 1 job to which we aspire
exercise in 1 future,
and that's 1 plus.
we grow in experience,
we learn how to behave in a professional environment,
we learn and discover the world of work.
In contrast,
to those who are in initial training,
we grow in experience,
so that tomorrow,
if you sign 1 CD and arrive in 1 company,
you know what to expect,
how you do it,
here you go.
And then we have so much more,
so much more.
As an alternator in France,
in particular,
we have the help of the driver's license,
uh, we have,
mobile help,
young Action Housing,
we have the activity bonus,
but we have so,
so much.
So,
go all out to the
training starting in September.